VOICE
From the blockbuster franchise that
nobody loves, but everybody likes
enough that they won't change the
channel when it's on cable, comes
the sequel that kinda sounds like a
high-speed handjob...
VOICE (CONT'D)
Fast Five.
Wait, they've made five of these
already?
VOICE (CONT'D)
Prepare for the biggest hit of this
street racing franchise...because
it got rid of all the street-
racing.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Now it's a heist film on wheels,
orchestrated by Vin Diesel...a
passable action hero...
VOICE (CONT'D)
Who this time must match wits with
a far more charismatic action hero:
The Rock...Who's jacked up on baby
oil
VOICE (CONT'D)
Together they'll crank up the NOS
on all the things you've come to
expect from a Fast & Furious movie,
like...
VOICE (CONT'D)
Gear-shifting
.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Mumble-growls..
You got my word Vince
Wughgh kinda counting on it
I remember everything about my
faaather
VOICE (CONT'D)
And overt homoeroticism.
To pull off one last job...Dom will
need to gather everyone's favorite
heist movie stereotypes:
VOICE (CONT'D)
The hunky mastermind
The nerd
VOICE (CONT'D)
The Bernie Mac
The guy who can't speak English
VOICE (CONT'D)
And the guy who's constantly
snacking.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Gear up to steal $100 million
dollars with the dumbest criminals
ever, as they...
VOICE (CONT'D)
Take off their masks during
robberies.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Go for leisurely strolls while all
of Rio's drug gangs are after them.
VOICE (CONT'D)
And drag-race cop cars they just
stole down the middle of the
street.
VOICE (CONT'D)
These heroes will stop at nothing
to take down a sort-of ruthless
drug lord, by...
VOICE (CONT'D)
Destroying poor neighborhoods...
Destroying rich neighborhoods...
VOICE (CONT'D)
Killing 22 cops with a giant metal
safe...
VOICE (CONT'D)
And ultimately leaving Rio in way
worse shape than they found it.
VOICE (CONT'D)
So refuel and ride along while
these rebels break every law in the
book...of physics...
VOICE (CONT'D)
Gravity!
Weight differential!
VOICE (CONT'D)
And friction!
Buckle up for the fifth film in the
franchise, that's technically the
fourth, since the events of Fast
Three take place after Fast Six,
making the third fast the sixth
fast, possibly the seventh
depending on where Fast 7 ends up in the timeline--Hey look! Car boobs!
VOICE (CONT'D)
UGH...we get it! You can nitpick movies!
But can you do this?
BOOBS!
CINEMA SINS VOICE
Ah, fair enough.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Thanks to the people at Cinema Sins.
Be sure to subscribe.
for more Honest Trailers
"All your base are belong to us"
"Hoof hearted"
"Banana Hammock"
"Lasso Lassie's Legendary Legless Lego-Legolas"
"Viewer discretion advised"
"My cat's breath smells like cat food"